- Okay, Sistine, so is this a true story?
- Uh-oh.
- Did your father like
throw you into sharks
at some point in your life?
- [Sophia] Oh, my God.
- See, it sounds crazy, and unfortunately-
- Well, it sounds like
someone should have called child services.
- [Sistine] It's true.
- But yeah.
- Fair enough. It's true.
It was a controlled environment
so it was very safe.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Living with the Sharks experience.
And my dad... I was
seriously afraid of them.
He thought it'd be funny to
throw some chum in my one-piece
and shove me right in.
- And she's also a horrible swimmer.
- And I'm bad swimmer, so
it was just a really...
I don't think I talked to
you the rest of the trip.
- No, you didn't.
- I was very upset.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I wanted to see if the sharks bite.
- No, you did not.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I got two other daughters.
- I got two other daughters. (clapping)
- Thank you.
- The fact that he was like-
- You know what?
- "I'm gonna put chum
in there," and then...
- [Sistine] I know.
Well now I know where I
stand on the leader board.
- (indistinct) Have you gotten him back?
- I did something a little naughty.
First season-
- [Sylvester] A little?
- I pretended I was pregnant.
- Can you imagine?
- I did.
- On camera.
- I mean on camera, so it... you know.
- She made a birthday cake with
all these goofy baby parts.
- No. By the way, Kelly,
it was my mom's idea.
So that's not me.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, I like doing something.
- Like baby parts, like, you know the-
- I actually thought he was
gonna have a heart attack
and I kept saying-
- Like Freddy Krueger.
- By the way, it was on his birthday.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I love your women so much in your family.
- We gotta dish it back, you know?
- [Kelly] I know. You threw
her into sharks with chum.
- I did.
- You've gotta like... She
gets like five more things.
- Thank you.
- That's so horrifying.
- The guys kept saying,
"Oh, they don't bite."
I go, "It's a shark.
"Maybe you have one there
that has emotional problems."
- By the way, we all got in the water.
Guess who stayed on the boat.
- The whole time.
- For sure.
- He did not-
- For sure?
- For sure.
- He didn't put his toe in the water.
We all swam with them the whole time.
- You can have the water,
I'm staying on the land.
The shark... you know what I mean?
Enough already.